hi it's Michele from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD and skincare nerd
and today I'm going to be doing a
routine review a while ago I broke down
through our Williams the skincare
routine and a lot of you guys liked it
so today I'm going to be breaking down
Alexandria Acacio Cortez's skincare
routine if you like this sort of video
give it a thumbs up subscribe to my
channel and click the notification bell
or notification bell if you don't want
to miss any videos here is a super quick
rundown of Alexandria or Kazuya Cortes
or AOC she's a Democratic Socialist and
her platform has a lot of things that
sound to me like really sensible ideas
like universal health care free college
action on climate change now I don't
really want to go too much into politics
because I know what's going to happen in
the comments so if you want to argue
with people flame them call them
whatever then go to other YouTube
channels like contra points so more
relevantly for this channel she posted
her skincare routine
earlier this year and so we're going to
break it down so this is from her
Instagram stories her first step in her
skincare routine is double cleansing she
says that if you wear makeup you should
double cleanse and what you do is you
cleanse with the bar more oil to melt
off the makeup then use a usual soapy
cleanser to wash your skin
now I double cleanse in my routine I
find it really effective for removing
makeup and so I think this is a pretty
good general piece of advice for most
people double cleansing is probably
going to help you remove makeup more
efficiently more gently without freaking
your skin out so by usual soapy cleanser
I'm assuming she means a foaming
cleanser a lot of people are scared of
foaming cleansers because in the past
they used to always be really harsh and
drying but in the last five to ten years
foaming cleanser technology has improved
a whole bunch and so now you can get the
foam without that harsh cleansing effect
I personally find that foaming cleansers
are a lot more effective for me because
you end up using a lot less product
because it spreads over your skin much
more easily
she says she also uses a face brush or
makeup towel when she's being good I
really think you need a brush or towel
to cleanse your skin well a lot of the
time if you're using these tools they
can stay damp and if you keep them in
the shower then this can start growing
mold and that can be even worse for your
skin I do think they feel like they're
cleansing more but in reality if you
have a good double cleanse routine if
you have good products then using a tool
to wipe off stuff isn't really necessary
she also says that she sometimes just
uses a nice face wipe before bed we've
all slept a make up the wipes are a
really good place to start if this is a
bad habit wipes in general aren't going
to be as good at cleansing as a double
cleanse but in a pinch they can be quite
useful I personally really like bioderma
sensibio wipes which I took on holidays
with me you might have seen that video I
also quite like Neutrogena swipes as
well the only issue with wipes is that
they're quite wasteful because each time
you are throwing away a whole wipe that
is mostly made of polymers she also says
no alcohol in your wipes or any skin
care product alcohol is not that bad for
your skin I've been meaning to do a
podcast about the science behind this
with my friend Steven who is a cosmetic
chemist it will happen the short version
is alcohol is not that bad for your skin
it might temporarily dehydrate your skin
a little bit but there's no evidence
that it does anything bad in the long
term and it's really unlikely to as well
so why is alcohol in there if it's not
doing anything good or bad it is
actually doing things that are good it
is making stuff spread better it's
making stuff maybe absorb better as well
depending on what the formula is so step
two in her routine is toner and actives
she says toner should not have alcohol
in it so there's more of this anti
alcohol stance which I don't think is
necessary it should be more nourishing
you can use plain witch hazel there's
lots of different kinds I don't think a
turn is really necessary in a routine
but it can help add a hydrating layer to
your skin actives are basically serious
with active compounds in general I think
a serum should really have active
compounds if it doesn't have actives
it's not really a serum in my opinion
but definitions of all of these products
types can change examples of active
compounds are vitamin C and retinol
which are probably the two best ones or
at least fresh noids
there should be in the layer closest to
your skin after toner that is a sensible
order step three moisturizer and
sunscreen
use the moisturizer that works with your
skin it should be personal everyone skin
is different completely agree you need
to find a moisturizer that is suitable
for your skin even if your skin is
really oily and greasy there will be a
moisturizer that works for you if you
need one some people don't even new
point if your skin is fine if it's not
dry or dehydrated or tight feeling then
maybe you don't need one my skin is oily
but it's dehydration prone so having a
moisturizer really helps if you want to
find out more about choosing a
moisturizer the lab nothing guides basic
skin care has a whole chapter on it then
sunscreen the most important thing
completely agree sunscreen is super
important it is the best anti-aging
product that you can possibly buy it's
also anti-cancer as well which is of
course a bonus because who wants cancer
not me the other good thing about
sunscreen is that if you're prone to
hyperpigmentation then it can help that
fade so things like acne mask will fade
much faster if you're protecting it from
the UV she's been using daily sunscreen
since she was 19 that is really
impressive it is a really good age to
start I think I started using daily
sunscreen when I was maybe 25 but of
course the best time to start using
sunscreen is now random other things she
experiments a lot with skincare and
tools like face brushes face masks eye
patches now with experimenting a lot
with your skin I don't think this is a
good idea if you have sensitive skin but
it sounds like she's worked out what
works for her skin and she can
experiment within those bounds she
considers her approach a blend between
k-beauty and scientific consensus
probably my approach - there are a lot
of really fun products and Korean beauty
but I think sometimes it is a bit
gimmicky and sometimes the science just
isn't there to support some of the
products it is fun though and it does
tend to be reasonably cheap so if you
enjoy it then do it her mom told her not
to touch her face or rest her face on
her open hand which is again really good
advice if you are acne prone she also
says that diet impacts a lot
she kept breaking out she cut out dairy
and her skin issues went away dietary
advice is really difficult from the
studies it looks like different things
will probably work for different people
and is so variable dairy is one of the
things that's being more studied but the
results are quite conflicting so for
example lower fat dairy seems to be
worse for acne and
study it's really inconclusive she says
skincare straight up a hobby of mine I'm
a science nerd and I truly enjoy the
science of it
reading about compounds and studies it's
like that hi if you're watching she gets
wipes next to her bed and at the very
least she wipes off her makeup this is
good advice I would also recommend maybe
using a micellar water with reusable
cotton pads if you want to be a bit more
environmentally friendly she says when
it comes to makeup don't use more than
you need you should incorporate double
cleansing or a makeup towel face brush
if you use it so you can totally clear
your skin at the end of the day let your
skin breathe I do think this will
prevent breakouts but not really because
your skin needs to breathe it's simply
statistically speaking if you're using
less products on your skin then you're
going to encounter less ingredients that
might break you up on greeting
combinations that break you up she does
talk about makeup as well and I think
it's really refreshing to see someone in
a position of power who shows that you
can have time in your day to do things
like makeup as well as be awesome and
political and fight for people's rights
so my overall rating of Alexandria
Acacio cortezes skin care routine is an
a triple plus it's pretty much the best
celebrity skin care routine I've ever
seen all the advice is going to probably
work for most people it's also really
detailed and most of the time when a
celebrity goes into a detail routine
there's some really dodgy stuff there
but there's nothing super dodgy at all
if you liked this video you can also
leave me a comment letting me know who
else's skincare routine you want me to
critique also give it a thumbs up
subscribe to my channel all that really
helps you can also follow me on
Instagram and check out my blog see you
next time for more nerdy talk about
skincare and beauty